there you go today we are having the a
group of football students they are
giving the work to Riverside Park and in
order for us to keep this part going we
have to have groups helping us we're
working there every day Monday through
Friday and you see the same people you
know walking their dogs down the street
they wave to us you know they say hi we
have other people come up and say you
know thank you it's been really cool to
be able to like work in the community
with people and kind of experience with
New York's really like this month that
we're spending here the athletes came in
and helped out with the pre-k classes
and they helped out in a variety of ways
they helped out by reading to the kids
they helped out with playing with them
taking them on trips and that was a huge
benefit for us I really like playing
with the kids because we work with kids
and it's just a great way to give back
and to meet new people one of the little
kids every day we come in you go see so
big and you're so big too and it's a lot
of fun to you know see their response
all right the ability to be able to
become part of a team and to integrate
yourself into a different society is is
valuable for us on the football field
it's obviously going to be valuable for
them in the classroom I mean the core
curriculum at Columbia thrives on
looking at different situations from a
different perspective so this all fits
together whether it be the academic
experience whether it be the career
development experience whether it be the
team experience you know on the field
all those things stem from your ability
to be able to interact see things from a
different point of view and integrate
yourself into different parts of society
when Columbia's a football coach
approached me about a desire to create a
community program for the football
freshman so they could be introduced in
New York and really understand about
what it means to be a leader and he made
it clear that he wanted to raise up good
citizens
it he cared about what happened on the
field greatly but he really wanted to
build good citizens and he said can you
help with pre-k we really want each kid
to be on hand with someone else and we
never have enough we can never afford
enough staff and we can never recruit
enough volunteers to manage you know so
that we have a one adult two two two two
children ratio but with the football
players coming in you know I mean they
could grab for kids in each hand
practically just because the size
difference it was amazing so it was
great to have their help to be able to
do all that this has been eye-opening
experience because I never saw this side
of our community before in New York City
and it's great to get in touch with our
new community for the next four years 30
31 to 30 degree environmental
stewardship is constantly working with
many different student groups across the
organization and so this is a perfect
opportunity for the football players to
fit right in with that game plan that we
have to bridge that gap between our
office and many different student groups
so that they can be ambassadors to the
community and educate everyone else
about sustainability and the right thing
to do it's like not even service work
for me when I'm outside helping the
environment you know I'm just so in sync
with with nature so I feel like it was
kind of a blessing to be placed on the
environmental stewardship team where I'm
really doing what I love and what I want
to do occupation wise when I get older
well may has been very helpful
and this Japanese children they need to
enter interact with the community and
this is the best way that they can
interact with the community working
around the people and doing stuff that
they they're going to experience what
this community is all about they were
able to then reflect this is something
we learned through service learning you
reflect on what sirs you've done and
what it means and why it's important and
through that reflection you get to then
think about who you are in this world
who are you what kind of leader do you
really want to be we as a group of seven
bonded more probably than any of the
other teams because we had to do more
team-oriented stuff all the players knew
that we'd be coming up in working around
campus in some type of way but we didn't
really know what exactly they would have
us doing I didn't expect to be as
involved with community and with the
city so as much as we were I think it's
definitely been a great experience a lot
of these guys are are from much
different places in New York City it's a
life lesson to learn how to interact a
little bit out of your comfort zone and
we start that as fast as we can and and
one of the residual positives obviously
is that they become more familiar with
with Columbia and the people here and
living and getting around and taking a
subway for the first time and doing all
those things so this is a win-win
situation for everybody involved and
this is just part of that and the fact
that it grows organically the fact that
these kids become better people through
this experience not only helps our
football team but it helps it helps
everybody involved with the University
and in our ultimate goal here is to
create a program that everybody can be
proud of